okay sending leads here and a question
there sometimes I get asked and I feel
like I need to address it is is being
introverted a bad thing bite for
business so do you need to be confident
and a speaker in order to be successful
now listen I don't think that you need
to be extroverted what I mean by that is
loud vocal but the definition of an
extrovert is someone that gets the
definition an expert is someone that
gets energy off other people she's not
my Wikipedia mouth my full-time dicks
are me just by my side just in case I
need somehow your kind of extrovert a
little if I had like a long day and I
need it's like recharge I want to be on
my own
mm-hmm great but like it's a lie how to
sleep I would be but the thing is people
would see you the very fact that you're
even on this video yeah and you're like
hanging and people some people are not
that why yeah you know so you might be
like hey I'm an extrovert introvert or
whatever I like to be alone sometimes
sometimes but but the thing is if you
are watching this video and you're not
like that you are in the back seat and
you'd be the camera come out and you'd
be you'd be in the boat cause you
wouldn't we're gonna be on the camera
you know the thought of just picking up
the phone makes you nervous if you're
that kind of a person can you succeed in
business and the answer is absolutely
yes because Oh a big part of business is
deal crunching spreadsheets numbers like
you don't need to be extra wet for that
sometimes my extrovert aids people nurse
wanting to this talk and big picture can
be a hindrance because loans do
paperwork and things like that it's
difficult for me so my attitude is
everyone's got different skills and you
need to use your skills to your best
ability if you're introverted and you
hate speaking and they're like being
social and the thought of a video camera
being on you makes me feel sick then
don't set up a YouTube channel because
that's probably not the best thing for
you to do you look great
yes play To Your Strengths so say if you
don't like be on camera maybe like write
a blog or radio or like there's always
different
or partner with someone who is and like
a Brando and someone that loves to write
and do articles and put themselves out
there and network partner with someone
that does that you can be the nerd you
can be the person that crunches the
numbers and finds the deals so there are
ok that's my general thoughts so through
an introvert good thing and another
thing is you said to me actually
yesterday you said to me why or cuz I
have a lot of people around my house and
the office to are multimillionaires very
very successful and you said why are all
successful people so like loud so
Messick and what I say listen why is it
is that's probably because that's the
kind of wealthy people that I attract
yeah you attract but there are some
people that are wealthy to have IT
businesses and you know whatever yeah
I'm in the creative industry so people
that come in my house probably tend to
be a bit like me the normal youtuber so
so not all not all rich people are
extroverted like that however okay this
is ramen slightly maybe some like I'm
contradicting myself a little bit but
I'm not you've got to be able to sell
you have to be able to sell now you
don't have to be an extrovert to sell
you don't have to sell in like a loud
way I might sometimes I'm in sales by
the way this is not an issue of
extrovert or introvert sales is an issue
of being able to ask the right questions
to make it easy for someone to do
business with you that's sales but you
can be the quietest humblest you know
introverted sales person and still be
really good I've known people but I've
been sold by I have I went in for a
massage
just just down the road from here and
the and the guy reception was such a
sales person even saying like so you
know when would you like to come in for
the exercise I'm like oh
I didn't realize and have micha
membership and it'll tell you about the
god selling Superman like really quite
hard selling to me and I liked it
because I like being sold to because if
you don't like being sold to then you
don't you can't then sell and you don't
realize that sales is actually serving
you try actually serve me but of course
enough money right so but he was
introverted
it wasn't like loud because the question
he was asking so I definitely think you
need the skills you need the basic
people skills and sense I'll sit here so
you can be in the room slowly edging
engineer
nobody should normally she's just like I
don't even play what do you film it or
whatever so so listen if you're
introverted be inspired be encouraged
you can be successful without trying to
be like an extrovert because the problem
is some people watch me on youtube and
watch Grant Cardone on watch all these
people and youtubers think they have to
be like that to succeed and they have to
be just like that I don't think that's
the case at all I know it's not the case
because I know a lot of a lot of my
students that are making you know
six-figure salaries from property as
entrepreneurs there are nothing like me
you know mini because you arrange the
dinners yeah and I've just for me like
the more you you are the more successful
you'll be play To Your Strengths be
aware just play to your strengths what
about Becky and John Becky and John
Becky Butler John Simmons together they
have social anxiety around people to the
point whereby they put off coming to the
crash course for ages and when they came
to the crash course because those like a
thousand people when they came and they
felt physically sick there just the fact
that I'm sorry physically sick now
they're making 10 grand a month
starting from scratch and they're just
themselves
so if you're an introverted person we
love you we encourage you we stand with
you we believe in you if you're
extroverted you're cool too but place
you strengths don't try and be anybody
else
and and just flip the cards if you need
to partner it with someone partner it
with someone if you're not good at
something if you're not going to finance
or numbers or sales or little over you
know if you can't get good then partner
up with someone and
yeah I just because I hope you enjoy the
video if you've got more questions
comment in below if you enjoy the videos
then wipe the thumbs up thing and
subscribe to the channel because I got
loads more cool videos come in and if
you've not been to the crash course how
good to the crash course so I love them
the crash course is the best that's
where you got started that's where we
first met at the crash course if you
want to meet me I tend to be pretty much
every crash course so and I do a lot of
the training if you want to meet great
people you want to get great knowledge
book on the crash course and you know
where we're gonna put the crash course a
little bit picture right over your face
right there you can't see no they can't
see you anymore they can't see you
anymore
so just wherever you lose face is then
you gotta click that and you then you'll
get to meet her you get to meet me and
you'll get to learn all the skills
alright so jump on my face right now did
it I don't even know what it did but
[ __ ] on
see you there guys